zeolite's work? Is there anyone who shouldn't use zeolite?
So zeolites fall into the category of keylaters. So a keylater is something that you absorb
across your gut membrane. So if you're taking it orally, you're absorbing that product and it's
basically searching out and grabbing onto things and pulling things out of your body.
So the companies that sell these keylaters say things like, well everybody's got heavy
metals, everybody's got toxins, so everybody should be taking a keylater on a daily basis.
The problem with that is that it may be true that everybody's got toxins and everybody has heavy
metals. But here's two caveats on taking keylaters. Number one is the process of keylation out
of the tissues is that you're grabbing stuff out of the tissues or out of the cells and bringing it
back through the lip system into the bloodstream. It's carried through the bloodstream through your
liver. And then your liver has to grab toxins out of the blood and put them through what's called
phase one, phase two, and phase three detoxification pathways. In phase three, it puts it into the
bile and then it's the bile travels down to the gallbladder. That's what I call phase four.
And from the gallbladder, it has to be secreted into the duodenum. That's the first part of the
small intestine. Then it travels through the small intestine and you want to make sure that your
intestinal transit time is good that you're not reabsorbing those. So you'll reabsorb toxins
that your liver does all this work through these different phases and get it into the gallbladder.
Your gallbladder does all this work to get it into the intestinal tract. Then if your intestinal tract
is slowly to your constipated, which I call phase six detoxification, then you have a greater risk
of a reabsorb that or if you have leaky gut issues. So if you have any intestinal permeability issues,
you can reabsorb those toxins. That's what I call phase five. So phase five is getting it through the
gut. Phase six is getting it into the toilet. So if you're you have to start with phase six. So I
explain this in detail in my book, the six, the seven phases of detox. So phase six is really the
end point, getting it into the toilet. Phase five is making sure you're not reabsorb it because
you have a damaged gut wall. So I don't think you should be doing zeolites until you heal the gut.
And then you make sure that you're using binders in the gut. So technically a binder,
zeolite can act like a binder as well, but zeolite is absorbed. So it acts like a key later. But
technically a binder will mainly stay in the gut and hold on to things in the gut so you don't
reabsorb them. So making sure that you have a healthy gut. So you're not reabsorbing things,
making sure you're binding things so they're you're not reabsorbing them, making them going backwards
again, going to the gallbladder. How's your gallbladder functioning? So if your gallbladder is sluggish
and it's not functioning well, then making sure you're cleaning out the gallbladder, you're flushing it
in different ways. There's different gallbladder flushes that one could do. So we're talking about
detoxification pathways here. So really, you have to work backwards from phase six to phase five to
phase four, three, two, one, and then you do phase zero, which is pulling stuff out of the tissue.
So shouldn't, how does zeolite work? It's mainly a key later. Shouldn't anybody not be taking zeolite?
Yeah. Anybody who has not dealt with the other phases of detoxification. If I have people that say,
I go every three days. Yeah, that's kind of it. I have a malgoma every three days. Okay, well,
you have no business doing any sort of detoxification. You need to get your malgoma improvements
in proper alignment. You eat corn today. You should see it in your malgoma the next morning.
That should be your test fill transit time. You should be feeling like you're getting everything
cleaned out on a daily basis. Super, super important. You've got got issues. You've got inflammation,
going back to doing a Syrex 10 panel, looking for food sensitivities. If you have inflammation
of the gut because you've got a ton of food sensitivities that you have a dealt with, you know that you
have damage cut border, then you could do a Syrex array two and three X to look for got barrier
issues if you want to. You know, you've got barrier issues already. You should have no business
doing zeolite or doing any sort of key later. You need to heal the gut first and then working that
way backwards. So I said there's two caveats to use in a key later. What is that you
is what I just explained that all your detox pathways are open and doing well. I've worked on healing.
My god, I have daily bowel movements really healthy. I know that I'm knocked up three absorbing things.
I'm taking a binder, you know, away from food to help grab onto things in the gut. I feel like
I got that all under control. Now I want to use zeolite. Well, there's one other caveat to using a
key later. So I have labeled key laders into categories of mild, moderate and strong key laders.
So a mild key later would be like clorella, a mild key later would be like modified citrus pectin,
a moderate key later. I have a blog post on it. So go look at our blog post on key laders and you'll
see that. But zeolite would fall into a moderate to a strong key later. And you have to be careful
with moderate to strong key laders if you have metal in your mouth. If you have mercury fillings,
you can look at your mouth. You have silver fillings and you really shouldn't be using heavy key laders
because you can pull those and you could just be making yourself more toxic. So you have to be careful
with that. There's that's a gray area around that. So that would be my only other caveat to
using zeolite or any heavy key laders is is do you have a metal in your tissue or do you have any
implanted devices that could make you worse. So I would stick to more moderate to more milder key laders.
Remember every you know that I would agree with the truth that probably everybody has heavy
metals. Everybody has toxins. It does it mean that you should always be trying to get rid of them.
The truth is you could do a heavy metal chelation your whole life and you're always going to have
toxins. It just is what it is. I don't really think that you're ever ever going to not have toxins
in your body. I just don't take that's a possibility. So that shouldn't be our purpose is to,
oh, I have to get rid of all the toxins in my body. That's really my purpose of life. That really
shouldn't be our purpose of life. Our purpose is to be as healthy as possible and to make sure that our
rate of detoxification exceeds the rate of our toxicification. That's a word. So we want to be working
on our detox pathways so that they're open and they're healthy. Our liver is healthy. That's one of
the most important thing. That's really your biggest stumbling block with detoxification.
With cellular detoxification is having a healthy liver. So things that we do to abuse our liver
abuses are really has some limiting factors at our rate of detoxification. That's a key factor.